Well,
so okay,
so your self serving and you construct
a view of the world that serves those
self serving causes and some
of that has to do with power.
Fair enough.
That doesn't mean it all
has to do with power.
It means that some of
it has to do with power.
It's like racism.
People are kind of racist or
maybe people prefer their ingroup.
It's not that easy or maybe people
prefer the familiar to the novel.
You know that I eat that.
The social psychologists have come up
with implicit association test that
measures unconscious bias.
We don't know what the hell that measures
the people who invented that bloody
thing.
They know.
We don't know what it measures.
They know it's not reliable.
They know it's not valid enough to
be used as an individual diagnostic
instrument.
That's technically the case.
They also know that you can't train
people out of their unconscious biases
because there was not much difference
between unconscious bias and instantaneous
perception,
but they don't really care.
I've written to Mazda and Bonci.
He's one of the inventors of
the IAT several times saying,
how about you come out in public
and say what you already know?
Which is that people are
misusing your damn test.
Silence.
Well,
that's partly because her discipline,
social psychology is a corrupt discipline
as the social psychologists have
discovered over the last four years.
It'd be turning themselves inside out
trying to rectify which they haven't.
Anyways,
we're giving the devil his due.
There's an infinite number
of interpretations of
the world and it's highly
probable that you'll lay a
self serving one on top of it.
Yes,
and also that will serve
the interest of your group.
However you define that.
Yes,
but it only accounts for a
fraction of your behavior.
There's all sorts of other things at
work as well and you don't get to reduce
all human motivations
to one motivation power.
And then you might also ask a,
why would you want to reduce
all human motivations to power?
It's so you can use power.
That's why you can justify
the use of power that's force.
You don't have to engage
in civilized debate.
You don't have to give
a damn about the facts,
especially if you're not a postmodernist
cause you don't believe in facts
anyways.
And you might ask,
well,
why don't you,
Hey,
I'm not kidding.
Postmodernists don't believe in facts.
They believe that the idea of fact is
part of the power game that's place played
by the white dominated male patriarchy
to impose the tyrannosaur structure of
the Patriarchy on the oppressors.
It's like I'm not making this stuff up.
It's embedded,
right?
In theory,
all you have to do is read
it and you find this out.
So they don't believe in facts.
What facts would constrain
the use of power?
At least that's how it looks to me.
Yeah.
Okay.
So fine.
We
gave the devil his due.
There's an infinite number
of interpretations and
you're likely to use bias,
compression algorithms on the world
and they're likely to be biased in your
favor.
True.
But
only partly true.
And the difference between an idiot log
and the thinker is that a thinker knows
the difference between things that are
only partly true and things that are
completely true.
Things are complicated.
Like,
I like to think everything is as
complicated as a military helicopter.
You have to like,
I think it's eight hours of maintenance
to keep those things in the air for one
hour because they don't
fly like they're rocks.
They plummet.
It's really hard to keep them in the
air and they're full of parts and you,
and if you don't know all those parts,
you don't go in there and monkey
about with them because just wreck it.
And that's just a helicopter.
Like everything is way more
complicated than the helicopter.
So you don't just go muck about in there
hoping you're going to make it better.
That isn't how it works.
You need to be competent.
All right,
so look,
here's where the postmodernists are wrong.
I think there's three places
and there's serious errors.
The first is that there is an
infinite number of interpretations,
but there is not an infinite
number of viable interpretation.
So there's a very finite number
of viable interpretations.
And I don't think that this is theory.
I think that game theorists have already
demonstrated this to some degree and
it's going to be built into
AI systems very rapidly.
Okay,
so what are the constraints?
first of all,
you can't have an interpretation that
leads to immediately to your death or your
dad.
Now,
if you want to be dead,
that's fine,
but if you don't want to be,
then you got a lot of limited options,
right?
You don't get to run naked across an
eight lane freeway at night blindfolded
because probably you'll be dead.
That's a bad interpretation.
Okay,
so you might say because you're
fragile and vulnerable and mortal,
that there's a limited number of ways
that you can look at the world that don't
result in,
let's say death or
serious damage or agony.
That's a bad thing.
Agony is a bad thing.
Most people agreed on that.
So you're constrained by pain and anxiety.
At least your interpretations
are constrained by pain
and anxiety and you know
you can make pain worse or better
by thinking about it to some degree,
but only to some degree
when push comes to shove,
pain is your master.
Okay?
So that's a big constraint.
That's a big,
big constraint.
Well,
but the constraints are worse than that
because not only do you not get to have
an interpretation of the world that
produces anxiety and suffering right now,
but you don't get to have
an interpretation of the
world that if you iterated
across time produces pain and suffering.
And so that's,
that's a big problem
because there's lots of,
you could go out tonight and get yourself
drunk on cocaine and sleep with six
hawkers and you know,
maybe that,
maybe that'd be a good night.
You know,
you might not think about
it being so good tomorrow,
but then maybe you're dead of AIDS in a
year or maybe you're addicted to cocaine
or maybe you're a street
alcoholic or whatever.
It's like as an iterable
game that's downhill.
And the thing is you play iterated games,
you don't play one,
you play iterated games.
And so your interpretation of the world
has to be one that will sustain multiple
iterations across time because you have
to worry about 40 year olds and 60 year
old you.
And that's a big problem.
That's a lot of used,
stretched over a long period of time.
And it's worse than that
because it's not just you.
It's like you and your family,
right?
And not only,
so,
not only do you have to take
care of yourself now in a
manner that allows you to
take care of yourself when you're 40 you
have to take care of yourself now in a
manner that takes care of you when you're
40 so that other people are happy to
have you around now and continually so
that they'll cooperate and compete with
you in a positive way.
And so that's getting
ridiculously complicated.
It's not just you.
Now,
when you in the future,
it's you surrounded by other people doing
the same thing now and in the future.
And there's a lot of other people,
it can even just be you and your family.
You know,
like,
like the psychopathic burglar mob
that's just not going to go so well,
right?
Other people are going to object
and the world's going to object.
And so fine,
there's an infinite
number of interpretations,
but it doesn't mean there's an infinite
number of viable interpretations.
In fact,
there are hardly any,
there are hardly any playable games.